mr. president chairman honourable
members I'm delighted that one of my
first official engagements in my new
rule in my new role as commissioner for
neighborhood and enlargement is here in
the European Parliament I'm also pleased
that we will focus on the prospect for a
European Union enlargement which remains
a top priority for the European
Parliament and for me personally our
discussion today is centered on the
Western Balkans and I'm pleased to see
so many reporters shadow reporters and
chairs of delegations to join to
parliamentary committees and also
colleagues from the national parliaments
from the Western Balkans we have quite a
bit to discuss before we do that let me
say a few words on what we need to do to
ensure that the region which is an
integral part of Europe has a credible
accession perspective first we need to
sustain and accelerate reform progress
for each individual country the focus
must be on the real impact of the
reforms on the ground the best measure
of progress will be the pace of economic
development increase prosperity and
quality of life as well as freedom for
people in our partners in the region
this is after all the ultimate objective
of the accession process I want to make
sure that the benefits are felt
throughout the region as swiftly as
possible second the Commission will
present suggestions early next year to
contribute to driving the process
forward to build on the Western Balkan
strategy of last year to strengthen our
cooperation and to render the
negotiation process more effective also
acting on concerns raised by member
states we will continue to put a strong
emphasis on the fundamentals of the rule
of law economic development the
functioning of a democratic institutions
and
administration reform these issues are
at the heart of the Society of
transformation all around the Western
Balkan and they need to undergo to be
ready for their eventual membership
strong political engagement is necessary
on reforms in the region not for the
European Union's sake but for the sake
of the citizens of the Western Balkans
the governments in the region
need to take responsibility to ensure
the reform process is inclusive with
wide stakeholder consultation
Parliament's have a key role in this
process also to be able to adequately
scrutinize the many legislative reforms
and proposals put before them but also
to make them work for the citizens of
these countries I also want the process
to be more dynamic and not just focused
on opening and closing negotiating
chapters we need to focus on identifying
opportunities for closer and earlier
integration in areas of joint interest
even before accession for example the
Western Balkans should be closely
associated associated with the Green
Deal or our Digital Agenda and our
trends will open networks in transport
and energy this will help drive growth
and create jobs so the people of the
region don't need to wait until
accession to reap the benefits of these
key policies the European Union must
also prepare for its part to be ready to
take onboard future member states once
conditions are met but not at the cost
of hampering the accession process the
process of deepening EU integration can
run in parallel with the accession
process honourable members let me say a
few words on each of the countries i
guess all of us were very disappointed
with the recent lack of consensus in the
European Council in October to open
membership negotiations we
the with Albania in North Macedonia
nevertheless our commitment to their you
perspective remains unchanged I will
continue to defend our proposal to open
accession negotiations with both
countries and I cannot stress enough the
importance of taking a positive decision
on opening negotiations before the
Zagreb summit of next year the creation
presidency has a crucial role to play in
this project
North Macedonia has delivered on what it
was asked it delivered even more by the
historic press / agreement which is an
inspiration for the whole region and for
Europe and despite the disappointment at
the outcome of the European Council in
October the country is continuing its EU
related reforms particularly in the
areas of rule of law but elsewhere as
well Albania has made significant
progress in the area of justice reform
including through the comprehensive
vetting of judges and prosecutors I am
convinced that these efforts must and
will continue let me also take this
opportunity to repeat that we stand in
solidarity with Albania following the
devastating earthquake and we will
continue to provide assistance we are
already looking into options on how to
do beyond the emergency needs Bosnia and
Herzegovina has also made important
steps on the EU path the opinion of on
the membership application provides a
comprehensive roadmap for for reforms I
welcome the nomination of the new
chairman of the Boston area governor
Council of Ministers mr. Zorin pega pega
Thea and I look forward to swift
formation and full functioning of all
executive and legislative authorities
this is crucial so that the country can
start addressing the kree priorities
identified in our opinion reforms in the
judiciary and management of migration
require timely action
turning to Kosovo with the certified
results of the early parliamentary
elections on the 6th of October
announced it is important that the new
government is formed swiftly there's a
hugely important work ahead including in
priority areas such as economic
development and the fight against
corruption and organized crime I look
forward to meeting the new leadership to
see how can the EU support their work we
also expect the new government to work
for a resumption of the EU facilitated
dialogue including by removing the
hundred percent tariff on imports from
Serbia and Bosnia Herzegovina which has
been in place for over a year now
High Representative Bora has already
said that the baguette question and
dialogue will be among his top
priorities and I will hope for all my
help to support him in this endeavor
which we hope to close already
by the end of next year before I move on
let me think that let me thank the cheap
observer of the EU election observer
mission to Kosovo this phone Cremant our
battle and other MEP is for their
outstanding work Montenegro is most
advanced country in terms of accession
negotiations with 32 chapters open three
of them provisionally closed work is
ongoing across the board and needs to
continue with the focus on tangible
results in particular when it comes to
the rule of law and media freedom the
political debate however in Montenegro
should return to the Parliament where it
belongs it is also vital to continue
ongoing work on electoral legislation to
address the low level of trust in view
of the parliamentary elections coming up
next October finally in the current
circumstances it is all the more
important that Serbia accelerates the
course of EU reforms Serbia is a
negotiating country with 13 chapters Oh
- closed and I'm happy to announce that
we are working to close one more chapter
still this year but when negotiating
country of course our expectations are
high
solid comprehensive and tangible results
on the ground are required in crucial
areas of democracy and rule of law as
well as when it comes to the freedom of
media in addition abroad and consensual
electoral reform is needed ahead of the
parliamentary elections of next spring
and the ongoing inter-parliamentary
dialogue facilitated by the European
Parliament is crucial in this regard and
now I'm more than happy to answer any of
your questions and again mr. president
it is always an honor to come to the
European Parliament which are continue
to do so
[Applause]